okay the second game now hopefully I
play and play bit quicker now yeah let's
go let's go with slow opening at least
try to avoid direct technical plane
let's just play really quickly now
yeah this is just under support
the just retreat not speeding up
development with 90 x 27
I just want to want to play a bit
quicker maybe this is not one hundred
percent grade but no sense to completely
outplayed opponent and then have no time
okay just a quick thing it's maybe going
nitey for
what I actually need to be a little bit
careful office e 2 e 3 + f2 some silly
sacrifices but I cover III now yeah of
course he was going to do that um but
it's not really really a problem you can
take on on c3 let still have the extra
ponent 22 nice bishops yeah you want
yeah
III was a threat i think
ok
just this one still covering everything
threatening a 4 okay yeah okay and just
just retreat this one covering c4
at some point you might get this pawn
back if it takes on c3 okay this is
interesting but I can I can just take
here there's some some trick
you not see three maybe could be okay
ticks with this pawn now before but then
I day for now cannot believe this 93 I
just take it off no I think I also have
be five now maybe bb5 take on da take on
you for 93 let's show off p 5 is really
a good idea okay come play it simple
just take this one group do you wanna
and it simply slow the extra porn in the
position it takes now Knight c3 f28 as
well ok so it couldn't take their if I
take on the phone knows as possible
Queenie for okie form look the edge
check Bishop f8 bit of age 6 system mate
look a faint mate
the queen is completely silly on a six
yes think so think so
I hope it's not a completely ridiculous
oversight it looks like a maid
yeah it isn't me today oh well at least
a nice game as compensation for for the
first one okay we give to me mainly 11
again I guess this is a almost Senate
result okay make sure to leave comments
or questions on youtube and also check
out the other comentary Vikings crochet
in this channel yeah thanks for watching
it listening bye